so let's talk about the royal family
[Laughter]
sorry
not them i keep forgetting this is fox
news
i mean the british royal family
specifically it's two former royal
members yeah royal member i should avoid
saying that around prince andrew
anyway one of their mutant offspring
showed up at the u.n and crapped on us
but i guess if you're gonna take a crap
there's no place better than that
i don't know i wonder if climate change
is wreaking havoc on our planet with the
most vulnerable suffering most of all
climate change wreaking havoc on our
planet
with the most vulnerable suffering most
of all
the few weaponizing lies and
disinformation at the expense of the
many
and from the horrific war in ukraine
to the rolling back of constitutional
rights here in the united states we are
witnessing a global assault on democracy
and freedom
so this fuzz ball
calls out the rolling back of
constitutional rights in the us as part
of a global assault on democracy and
freedom
well he knows his audience bad mouth in
the u.s at the u.n is the easiest way to
get applause it's like standing in front
of an auditorium of high school kids and
saying marijuana should be legal
everywhere and oh yeah no more homework
and pizza every day in the caf
seriously was it a speech or a job
interview you want to ingratiate
yourself to the world's tyrants and
trash or host country fine you pick the
right place you royal douche and you
pick the right country
america will actually put up with your
desperate need for attention and status
you know i'd compare them to the
kardashians but that would be an insult
to people who take pictures of their
butts
so should we care about him or them not
really but what else do you want to talk
about how odor eaters are made or what
kim jong-un is bench pressing or the
price of bubble gum cigars how about
vultures did you know we're seeing a
dangerous decline of vulture populations
which could lead to the spread of deadly
diseases like the plague and rabies
which is good because i'm tired of
everything being made in china
you know
vultures are vital by eating corpses
which helps keep ecosystems and
pathogens in check not to mention a
great way to hide evidence right cat
so in terms of the planet vultures do
way more good than prince harry harry
can fly around the globe lecturing us on
climate as he harms it but a flock of
vultures can pick a dead panther clean
before brian stelter can even get his
bib on
so
is that a fair comparison the prince and
a vulture why not one feasts on the dead
the other feast off the brain dead
and it reminds you that america truly is
the land of opportunity for opportunists
especially for the people who game the
system through woke drop dramatics if
you want to make a buck just kick up the
old depression theater and let it rip
like eric swalwell after chipotle
and anyone can do it including a dopey
prince with hair that looks like a
brillo pad used to get rust off a lawn
chair
i should invite him over to scrub my
pots
i kid i don't scrub pots i let the
little lady do that
oh sexist would say
it's terrible stuff but look harry's
just another [ __ ] the media loves to
briefly elevate like aoc and michael
avenatti except in this case he gets
favored status because he's a prince
that's it so prince harry bemoaning
privilege is like amber heard
complaining there's poop in her bed
he's the face of entitlement
and now he's here on us
but if it's so bad why the hell did he
move here you know we're in tough times
and this creep badmouth says to a bunch
of clowns while his wife mindlessly nods
like an audience member at the taping of
a view or the taping of the view
he somehow believes this cartoonish
wokism can erase his royal stain
he's hiding his crown and replacing it
with a hat
we can leave that in there
it's one word
it's an actual thing
look it up
i was speaking to the producer but if he
but if he believed that being royalty
was cutting in line then why come here
and cut in line again and expect to
become another simon cowell wannabe now
if he hates status he would have stayed
in his country and fixed things you know
start with the teeth
become a dentist
but instead of rejecting the
entitlements of royalty you exchange it
for the american version celebrity
royalty with your seething wife you two
in the u.n deserve each other you're a
throuple which combines throw up and
couple
fact is
the fact is harry
marrying an american doesn't make you
american it neither does criticizing
america with your undergrad notions of
global affairs and total ignorance of
our country just makes you embarrassing
in two countries not just one just like
james corden
i don't know
was that worth it fact is
our royals are better
george brett
brett saberhagen
dan
the duke of quisenberry
you know talk about real royals and they
never married their cousins
that we know of at least it didn't say
that on the back of my baseball cards
so maybe it's not harry's fault for
being stupid you know it's the first
thing we did after we kicked their asses
in the american revolution
embrace the second amendment not your
second cousin
[Applause]
he's such a car guy jesus asks him to
take the wheel host of the adam corolla
show and author of the great new book
everything reminds me of something out
of corolla
[Applause]
she's so sharp i can't go running with
her former state department spokeswoman
and founder of polaris national security
morgan ortegas
and
black cats consider seeing her a sign of
bad luck fox news contributor cat tip
and finally they sell as old socks as
sleeping bags my massive sidekick in the
nwa world television champion tyrus
thank you for your marvelous book it's
like all your other books it's a fast
and fun read thank you it's like a
breezy ride through a sunny day
i don't know why i said that he just
slipped into a douche commercial i did
i should be walking i should be walking
on the beach you have that not so fresh
feeling read my book
how did you know i didn't read it
[Laughter]
so what do you you said something before
the show but i'll let you say we you
have a you have a kind of an uh a
guttural response to uh prince harry
don't you
i'm bothered by him yeah by a lot like
way more than i should be bothered by
him because i hate ingratitude and
ingrates and people who come to this
country and beat it up and
it drives me insane i ill han omar
drives me nuts for the same reason like
you came here we saved you we put our
hand out and you're crapping in it and
there's more and more that in this
country and it drives me saying
especially for super ultra privileged
people who don't do jack squat and have
never earned anything in their lives and
by the way he's got to get the wall
trimmer out and go full jason statham
yeah at this point yes at this point it
bugs me
that that bothers me maybe that's why he
hates climate change so much is screwing
his hair up man
the heat the humidity yes yes he's got
to do what his brother did
you know he's got the bald thing morgan
morgan you you uh you have a weird
relationship with the royal this royal
couple don't you uh i've never met
prince harry um i i do think it's
particularly strange to have um a speech
about nelson mandela to have a white guy
a white prince is the one that's
remembering mandela maybe we could have
picked someone else right maybe someone
more in that fashion but way to evade
the question i am evading the question
out of it uh yeah i i you were good
friends with i wanted to tell you as
good friends she we went to a wedding we
did some stuff together when she lived
in new york um and you know she's um the
person that i will say this the person
that she is in front of the world today
does not surprise me ooh
so you're saying she's a [ __ ]
right
you can say it she doesn't watch this
show
yeah well you never know you're the the
highest rated show in late night she
might
that's how you do it that's how you get
out of tough questioning america
i was a press secretary i was a press
secretary i should be able to get out of
that question
that was pretty good thank you i
completely lost my train of thought oh
good iris it worked the problem i think
isn't it the problem that he came here
saying that he rejected the entitlements
of royalty and now is it kind of
expecting more royalty or more
entitlements from america
i you know
why are we even talking about this guy
because it's fun he is a like this dude
is the most un
famous royal family he's the ringo star
of royalty like nobody
he was booed the last time he was home
like you haven't seen that since like
the english famine where they're like
booing the royalties
they don't want him there then he comes
here and we don't want him here either
but this is america so everybody gets to
stay but he's so irrelevant
and the u.n is hurting so bad for guests
they literally brought him on and the
one thing he is doing and i think if i
was british i would be upset for a long
time britain's had the british people
have had this run of everyone with an
english accent is intelligent like
they're in all the movies all the
professors are always english that's
true he's single-handedly going to take
it away from them that's right
[Laughter]
the only thing they have
yeah that's a great point see that's why
we did it
yeah he's just he's not even on the list
like
you can't get any princes who can't get
a royalty oh there's that one guy who
keeps calling uh bring him on like
yeah cat uh are we being too hard on
this couple
or not hard enough
no
no on what all of it
i just he's like the whiniest prince
ever yeah like you're you're a prince
i i don't know i mean it's crazy to be
born into such insane levels of
privilege and also he's and just like
wine all the time he's also not very
good at talking like at all uh and he's
being offered you know triple digit
millions from netflix and all these it's
like you know
i think that's because you are a prince
so maybe he could at least acknowledge
that like hey like the the fact that i
was born a prince that that was good
you know say something positive every
now and then yeah and that's coming from
me yeah no but i think what they
yeah you are it's hard they want to be
the like the president and first lady of
like progressivism that's kind of they
felt that that would be their way in and
even in hollywood it seems like they're
already tired of them but i don't know i
don't live there well think about what
hollywood does we take people who
pretend to do something and turn them
into deities you know we're masters at
worshiping people who actually do
nothing like you you play a physicist in
a movie you play an action hero but you
really do nothing and kick no ass but we
act as if you do yes and that's why
hollywood loves these idiots
and on that note
up next crime victims who fight back and
show the courage wokesters hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else